le comité d'accueil était bien en place
à nevers agnès buzyn a fait son arrivée
sous les huées aux états généraux de la
santé des manifestants de clamecy et
cosne sur loire venu rappeler à la
ministre les menaces sur leur
établissement
on a besoin effectivement qu'elle puisse
se rend aux comptes hors de l'état
sanitaire de ce département 2 de la
détermination de la population et de ses
élus et trois de la volonté de dialogue
qu'il reste à mettre en oeuvre
concrètement sur notre territoire et une
visite attendue
il ya un peu plus d'un an emmanuel
macron alors en campagne avait affirmé à
l'hôpital de nevers l'importance de ne
pas délaisser les territoires ruraux
depuis la maternité de caunes à fermer
les urgences de nuit de clamecy sont
menacés et la nièvre a encore perdu des
médecins sans grande annonce la ministre
de la santé a tenu à rassurer
transposition des mutualisations de
licence mais que je vous garde
vous avez pourtant chance de sortir
j'entends que aujourd'hui la situation
est très angoissante pour la population
française partout que j'ai mis en place
ce plan d'accès aux soins je suis
absolument certaine que la nièvre sera
trouvé des solutions innovants que nous
pourrons peut-être d'ailleurs déployé
sur d'autres territoires
innover expérimenté c'était bien le but
de ces états généraux
écoutez patients praticiens et proposer
des pistes pour assurer l'égalité des
soins sur tout le territoire
beaucoup de gens sont démunis sont dans
les reins errance médical donc oui il ya
urgence pour qu'on puisse m
les choses donc en place on propose des
solutions
on va les mettre on va les étudier on va
les mettre en place on va les évaluer
on est prêts vraiment à travailler en
toute transparence et on veut que on
nous aide à tirer des étudiants en
médecine développer la prise en charge à
distance dégager du temps de pratique
médicale
agnès buzyn a promis d'accompagner les
initiatives
reste à les voir se concrétiser pour que
les états généraux apporte de réelles
avancées pour la nièvre en matière de
santé